I think the very few people see the
words excellence or consensus as
anything other than the most positive of
words these are the habits that most
people seek to cultivate they wish to be
part of the consensus they wish to be
excellent in both their behavior and
hope for excellent outcomes I think the
problem is is that we didn't realize
that excellence so far as it goes is
fine but it's involved in a trade-off
and that trade-off has to do with the
fact that excellence is really about
quality control it's about the fact that
if I'm going to go for let's say a
classical music concert
I want to assume that the piece will be
played flawlessly and I will concentrate
only on the interpretive aspects of the
piece above that but in fact quality
control can be deadly for example in a
jazz date where an improviser takes few
risks the music may be pleasant enough
his background music but it's scarcely
the sort of thing that would have
animated the bebop generation who played
live dates under open mic conditions
never knowing what would happen next
perhaps the most famous jazz album of
all time was Miles Davis kind of blue
and if you look at the sheet music for
that date almost nothing was written
down it was just a question of bringing
the most amazing minds together and you
can even hear a few flaws on that album
which make it so excited so I think that
the problem is is that we have to
realize that excellence is about hill
climbing it's about the fabled 10,000
hours it's about practice making perfect
and this is something that to the credit
of excellence is something we do know
how to teach perhaps we don't know how
to teach everyone how to achieve it but
there's always a class of people who
through dedicated repetition will be
able to bring their variants under
extraordinary pressure so that they are
reliable members of our society we want
this in our surgeons often we want this
in our musical classical music
but the question is do we want it
everywhere and because we do know how to
teach excellence
we've blinded ourselves to the role that
a different thought process is involved
in which I would associate with genius
the key question is who are these high
variance individuals why are our schools
filled with dyslexic why are there so
many kids diagnosed with ADHD my claim
is these are giant underserved
populations who are not meant for the
excellence model they are meant to be
the innovators the people who bring us
new forms of music that others will seek
to perfect and hone in their performance
but these are the sorts of people who
bring us new scientific vistas who
explore new terrain and what we've done
is we've created a system which
effectively demonizes these different
patterns we even call these things
learning disabilities when in fact if
you look at the learning disabled
population they very often are the most
intellectual accomplished members of the
society but we put them through a
torture chamber of K through 12
education where we attempt to convince
the teachers who have no idea how to
serve this population we try to make
sure that there is no indication that
there are teaching disabilities by
pushing the responsibility on to the
students these are the learning disabled
but in no real terms is this population
learning disabled it's a different and a
somewhat alien population that we have
tried to machine to a point where they
look as close to the excellent
population as possible so it's not
really that I'm against excellence what
I'm really against is the idea that
we've absorbed the concept of excellence
into the very fabric of our society so
that all those who don't function within
that idiom feel that they are somehow
aberrant and less than when in fact
these are the people who are going to
cure our cancers these are the people
who are going to create the new
multi-billion dollar industries and in
fact the problem is is that we don't
realize that genius is really about
adaptive Valley crossing it's about
taking on risk taking on cost doing
things that make almost no sense to
one else and can only be shown to have
been sensible after the fact because in
fact and I think Jim Watson said this
beautifully he said if you're really
going to do anything big you're by
definition unqualified to do it so the
entire culture of credentialism of
professionalism is really a culture of
excellence but in fact society is run by
power laws the very thick tails of these
distributions suggest that life isn't
normally distributed but distributed by
power laws and we need a special class
of people to play those tails to get us
the returns to power us forward an
advanced society and so what I'm really
interested in is not being blinded by
excellence to the prospects for other
modalities in particular genes